c'est moi julien martens j'suis
hollandaise mais ça fait dix ans que je
vis aux états unis j'adore chanter et
aussi regarder des films avec ma
meilleure amie d'anne
ma vie est absolument
parfaite quoi on déménage on retourne
aux pays-bas le pays des sabots des
moulins à vent et la bouffe des gueules
bienvenus
aux pays bas
c'est un troupeau de bisons n'ont que
cette journée sportive 90% gus coûté 2
pour saint servan tout le monde
appartient à klan ici dans ce qu'il sait
tout le monde rejoint gonds appelant le
club pay back que le plan des rappeurs
le coeur des blogueuses le coran vous
était complet et le pire de tous le clan
via clairac d'or qui nature but dans la
vie être vénéré je crois qu'on en arrive
l'autre les filles tu seras donc une
minute tu es le club
ces losers une mine et c'est reparti
pour une nouvelle année nouveau souffre
douleur
nous finirons l'année avec
[Musique]
ici c'est mon école je peux faire
exécuter la minute via de takrit rascals
de talend quoi la minus martens m'énerve
de plus en plus pour les yeux et bien
comme ça tu pourras t'entraîner choisi
une personne dans le public et ne chante
que pour elle
[Musique]
témoin cette dirait de retourner aux
états unis si j'avais eu votre fils
avoir la moyenne en anglais qui retourne
[Musique]
deux minutes je trouve absolument
partout
[Musique]
on espère
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
maman